mit spürhunden taschenlampen und
wärmebildkamera sucht die polizei in
brandenburg nach zwei unfallopfer dieser
äußerst mysteriöse verkehrsunfall
ereignet sich montagabend zwischen den
orten davids und wallendorf vermutlich
kommt beim einsetzenden nebel der
unfallwagen von der fahrbahn ab und
knallte gegen einen baum
die wucht des aufpralls ist so stark
dass dieser dabei gespalten wird das
fahrzeug kommt erst auf den wurzeln zum
stehen
das merkwürdige an dem fall als die
einsatzkräfte der feuerwehr am unfallort
eintreffen fehlt von den insassen des
wagens jede spur
mit einem großaufgebot von polizei
rettungskräften und hundestaffel wird
das gebiet weiträumig abgesucht
wir wollen hier in unserer eigenschaft
als rettungshundestaffel vor ort das
heißt wir hatten einen windräder im
einsatz der die spur des vermissten
aufgenommen hat bisher im blick verfolgt
hat und dort wollten wir dann im
anschluss die flächen runde um den
einsatz bringen und los wollte beat
weiträumig ab
im unfallwrack werden von der polizei
mehrere flaschen alkohol gefunden es
wird vermutet dass der fahrer des autos
möglicherweise betrunken gewesen ist und
deshalb mit seinem beifahrer vom
unfallort flüchtete
die suche bleibt bis in die frühen
morgenstunden erfolglos die polizei
bricht den großeinsatz anschließend ab
möglicherweise wurde über den
fahrzeughalter eine spur zu den
unfallopfern gefunden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren